-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Tonight Show."
Well, guys, big news
around the building today.
The new Rockefeller Center
Christmas tree
has been selected.
And, yeah, it's an
80-foot-tall Norway spruce
from Upstate New York.
Yeah.
And the tree is 80 feet tall
or 81 feet
in Ron DeSantis's heels.
[ Laughter ]
And --
It's exciting.
Let's get to some news here.
Today, following
Donald Trump Jr.'s testimony,
Eric Trump took the witness
stand in the civil fraud trial
against his dad.
Oh, it was really cute.
Eric still had a little green
makeup on his face
from his Hulk costume.
Yeah, it was cute.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's actually convenient
that all the Trumps
have testified now,
because they're going to use
the courtroom sketches
for their holiday card,
and I think that's smart.
[ Laughter ]
I think it's touching.
Yeah.
Hey, I want to say congrats
to the Texas Rangers,
who just won their first
ever World Series.
Congratulations.
[ Applause ]
It's very exciting.
And after the game,
MLB commissioner Rob Manfred
went down to the field
to congratulate them.
Let's see how that went.
-[ Voice cracking ] 63 years
is a long time to wait,
but the Texas Rangers
are World Series champions.
[ Laughter ]
-It was a busy time
for the commissioner.
In one night, he celebrated
the World Series
and, apparently,
his 13th birthday.
And I think that's very...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
[ Voice cracking ]
"They played great."
[ Laughter ]
"I'm McLovin, and..."
[ Normal voice] Well, guys,
it's been a week
since Congress elected
a new speaker of the House,
and he's not the most
famous guy in Washington,
but we've all had a week
to get to know him,
which means it's time
to play that classic game
"What's the Speaker's Name?"
-"What's the Speaker's Name?"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right. The game is simple.
I'm going to ask you, "What is
the House speaker's name?",
and to help you out,
here is a photo.
All right.
There he is.
Okay, Tariq, you're up first.
What is the speaker's name?
-Uh, I want to say Greg Smith.
[ Buzzer ]
-Ah, not quite.
Quest, you're up.
Tell us, what is
the speaker's name?
-Damn.
I was gonna say Greg Smith.
Roger Stevens?
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh, I'm afraid not.
Mark, your turn.
What is the speaker's name?
-I think I've got it.
Is it Mark Kelly?
[ Buzzer ]
-Ooh, that's --
That's your name, Mark.
-I knew it sounded familiar.
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
Let's try this again.
He's the third most powerful
person in the United States.
What is his name, Tariq?
-Nancy Pelosi.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
-George Santos.
[ Buzzer ]
-Tim Speaker.
-You think the House speaker's
last name is "Speaker"?
-I do, yes.
[ Thunder crashes ]
-Ooh, guys, you know
what that means.
It's time
for the lightning round.
And I'll even accept
his first name only.
Ready, go!
-Carl!
[ Buzzer ]
-Uh, Tom!
-Tim.
-No! Keep trying.
-Kevin.
[ Buzzer ]
-Nick.
-Brian!
[ Buzzer ]
-A.J.
-Howie!
[ Buzzer ]
-No, those are
the Backstreet Boys.
-Chase!
[ Buzzer ]
-Marshall!
-Rocky.
[ Buzzer ]
-Skye!
-No, those
are "Paw Patrol" dogs.
[ Sad tuba plays ]
Oh, that sound...
[ Cheers and applause ]
That sound means
that we're out of time.
I'm afraid none of you
could guess the speaker's name.
-Jimmy! Jimmy!
Can I guess?
-Uh, yeah, sure.
You in the audience, go for it.
-Is it Greg Smith?
[ Buzzer ]
-They already guessed that.
I'm so sorry.
What is your name, sir?
-Me?
I'm Mike Johnson.
-That's it!
That's the speaker's name --
Mike Johnson!
Catch me!
-Oh! Whoa!
Stop tickling me!
Oh! Oh!
Crowd surf! Crowd surf!
Let's go!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Breathing heavily ]
Anyway, in other news, um...
[ Laughter ]
You guys hear about this?
Today, The Beatles
released a new song
called "Now and Then,"
features all four members
of the band.
Yeah, for younger viewers
who don't know
how huge the Beatles were,
just imagine four Taylor Swifts
in matching suits.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
That's who they are.
Well, the the fifth
and final season
of "Stranger Things"
is still in the works,
and the producer says
that they will not use A.I.
to de-age the actors
and make them look younger.
He thinks that they can
still pass off as kids.
I don't know.
Take a look at the trailer.
-School's out, and it's time
for one last adventure
with the whole gang.
And of course, Eleven.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't know.
Some more TV news.
Paramount just announced
two new "Yellowstone" spinoff
series, called
"1944" and "2024."
Basically, at every
Paramount pitch meeting,
someone tosses out a year, and
the boss is like, "Let's do it."
[ Laughter ]
"Sounds good."
I saw that, this week,
both Starbucks and Dunkin'
debut their holiday menus.
-Oh.
And it's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, but it's very interesting
to compare the two chains.
I mean, take a look
at the Starbucks
holiday menu announcement here.
-'Tis the season at Starbucks.
Stop in today for a peppermint
mocha or caramel brulée latte
and taste the holiday spirit.
-Yeah. That's nice.
Now let's see Dunkin's.
-Christmas is almost here,
bitch.
Get your ass over here
and suck down a frappa mocha.
Who gives a [bleep]
And we'll throw in
a free pack of Marlboros.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
I just...
I just find that interesting.
Hang on. There's
another Starbucks video.
Let's check this out.
-Did someone say eggnog?
You will "nog" be able
to resist our egg-nog latte.
[ Giggles ]
Try one today at Starbucks.
-I love that, you know?
Let's see.
Can we see Dunkin's now?
-Did someone say egg nog?
Well, they should shut
their frickin' mouth.
It's still November.
We got watery coffee
and some old spider doughnuts
we got to get rid of.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-We're getting word.
There's another one.
-Really?
-Here's another one --
another one from Starbucks.
-There's no need to attack
our menu offerings.
We are just trying to spread
holiday cheer at Starbucks.
-Oh, spare me that
holier-than-thou crap, Donna.
You're just bitter
'cause I never called you back
after we hooked up.
Dunkin'.
-[ Chuckles ]
He's lying.
I would never.
Starbucks.
-Oh, come on, Donna,
don't gaslight me. Dunkin'.
-Oh, shut up, Ronnie.
It meant nothing,
and you friggin' know it.
Starbucks.
-Donna, oh, my God!
Don't you dare
tear my heart out like this!
Donn-a-a-a-a!
-Happy holidays
from Tim Hortons. Sorry.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Now -- okay.
I -- Now I know what it is.
I get it.
[ Applause ]
Hey, listen to this.
Today, the FDA proposed
banning a harmful chemical
that is added to many sodas.
Yeah, and one guy chugging
Mountain Dew Code Red was like,
"Wait. This isn't
organic Code Red?"
[ Laughter ]
"I'm used to
farm-to-table Mountain Dew."
[ Laughter ]
Guys, well, get this.
A 13-year-old
just broke a world record
by popping 20 balloons
suspended from a rotating pole
in under a minute,
while doing backwards
somersaults on a trampoline.
[ Laughter ]
Wait a minute.
Is -- Is that true?
-Wait.
What's wrong, Jimmy?
I knew this day was gonna come.
Sad piano.
[ Sad piano music plays ]
[ Laughter ]
-What's --
What's going on with you?
-Dramatic spotlight.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait, wait.
Is this about the kid
breaking the world record?
-Yeah. I just -- I thought
it wouldn't happen so soon.
I thought I'd have more time
to savor the view
from the mountaintop, you know?
-Well, yeah, sure,
if you're the one
who held the previous re--
Wait a minute.
Did that kid break your record?
-Yeah, he did.
Once it was I who was
the toast of the town,
the guy on the trampoline
who popped balloons
with an ease and grace
that few could
even dream of doing.
And then along comes a kid
who stole it all from me,
just like that.
[ Snaps fingers ]
Took me decades
to master that trick.
Years of my life,
skipping dental appointments,
birthdays, holidays,
more dental appointments,
colonoscopies,
more dental appointments.
I put my life on the line
in a never-ending quest
to be the king,
and now I have to decide
if I want to stay down
like a boxer who's been punched
too many times in the face,
or do I want to pick myself
up off the mat
and go another round?
Do I even have the fire in me
for another fight?
Is the lion inside me too tired
to protect his throne?
-Well, what are you gonna do?
-[ Breathes deeply ]
I'm gonna take back
what's mine.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
-Mark my words.
I'm coming for you, kid!
Because I'm about
to pop 21 balloons
while suspended from a rotating
pole in under a minute
while doing backwards
somersaults on a trampoline!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Moving on.
And finally,
a new study found
that cats have 276 different
facial expressions.
Yep, 276 expressions,
and they're all
subtle variations
of "Get away from me."
We have a great show.
Give it up for The Roots,
everybody!